let's continue our conversation about
the turbulent reversals from former
White House propaganda Steve Bannon
Steve Bannon is now describing that
infamous Trump Tower meeting with the
Russian lawyer as treasonous and
unpatriotic in a new book he was
speaking to Michael Wolfe Michael Wolfe
wrote a book called fire and fury inside
to the Trump White House it's reportedly
based around 200 interviews with not
only Donald Trump himself but also very
very important staffers and inner circle
members the meeting in question if
you've forgotten about it is this now
infamous meeting in Trump Tower attended
by Jared Kushner and Paul Manafort and
Donald Trump jr. and several others with
this Russian lawyer Natalia vessel
Mnet's kaya and it's the meeting where
this quid pro quo was intimated by
Donald Trump jr. that if the promised
Russian dirt on Hillary from the
Russians helps Trump win the
presidential election that then the
Trump administration would be willing to
look at easing Russian sanctions quid
pro quo very clearly intimated during
this conversation and in the aftermath
Bannon crushes the entire thing in the
new book and again as I mentioned
calling it treasonous and adding quote
even if you thought that this was not
treasonous or unpatriotic or bad s and I
happen to think it's all of that you
should have called the FBI immediately
this is Major
okay this is someone who for whatever
reason he's decided he wants to say this
publicly at least said it to Michael
Wolfe and now it's in a book the fact
that someone so high up in Trump's inner
circle is straight up saying the FBI
should have been called
I believe it's treasonous and I believe
it's unpatriotic that is a stunning
stunning thing or someone so close to
the president to be admitting and it
makes a lot of other questions come up
as well like for example is Bannon
worried that he might be implicated and
is he trying to distance himself from
what went on I actually don't really
think too strongly about that I for
whatever reason and I might be naive or
just incompetent or ignorant here but I
actually think that Bannon and Kellyanne
Conway a lot of negative things I can
say about them I don't actually think
they were
part of the majority or any of the
Russian stuff I don't know why I think
that I just don't think they would throw
Mike Pence in that group too maybe pens
as well I think pence was maybe
deliberately looking away from it
Steve Bannon also said to Michael Wolfe
that quote they're going to crack Don
junior like an egg on national TV
doesn't bode well for Donald Trump jr.
either so one possibility is Bannon
really wasn't involved and now he's
making it clear that all along he
thought there was shady stuff going on
the other possibility of course is that
yeah he was involved and he's trying to
distance himself publicly but I don't
think that said the third possibility
remember he was chief propagandist after
all is just to say things that will
create chaos because we know that Trump
generally benefits from chaos and that
would be the one that is most charitable
in terms of the calculated nature of
this which is Bannon is saying you know
I'm out of the White House and there
might be the perception that I'm feuding
with Trump in the White House but I'm
really not what can I do that might be
good here let me go out and say
something that will create chaos and
impact the news cycle merely because
chaos is good for the White House I
don't know I think there has to be
something there because it certainly
flies in the face of the Trump defense
mechanism of just saying oh we had never
run a campaign before we weren't we
didn't know that you're supposed to
contact the FBI and go about it in a
better way I guess maybe so I I and and
they've not gone to that much recently
they've blamed some of those missteps on
others Oh Pappa Doppel Asst was the only
guy who did something wrong and
everybody else was in the clear and
Michael Flynn did something kind of
wrong but it really wasn't that bad and
there's no collusion whatever how will
this play among Trump supporters who
have been loyal
not only to Trump but also to the sort
of ban and Breitbart propaganda complex
as well are they going to pick a side
here do they merely become completely
cognitively dissonant and not feel the
need for pick aside for picking aside
and just kind of rationalize away the
fact that on the one hand they support
Trump and on the other hand they see
Steve ban and as this brilliant guy but
at the same time Steve Bannon is saying
that something that the campaign did is
treasonous and unpatriotic maybe that's
the way they go which is just not even
think about I think that's a very slim
demographic to
no if even a majority of Trump
supporters supports the Bannen I don't
know the answer to that yeah that's a
good question I don't know what portion
of committed Trump is still see Bannon
as just this sort of brilliant political
operative that that at least some
believe the guy to be I don't know the
answer to that but 2018 is getting off
to a very very fast start